et on commence cette émission avec vous
Rémy Ferro bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de Paris également
président du groupe Paris en commun au
Conseil de Paris c'est à dire la branche
socialiste de la majorité municipale dan
Hidalgo dans un instant on va parler de
la visite hier d'Emmanuel Macron dans le
département de l'Hérault mais d'abord un
mot un regard sur cette semaine
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a essayé de
tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites avec ce chantier des 100 jours
un retour au contact des Français est-ce
que vous avez été convaincu par cette
semaine du président non mais peu
importe que j'ai été convaincu ce qui se
voit c'est que les Français n'ont pas
été convaincus ça me donne le sentiment
que Emmanuel Macron veut tourner la page
des retraites
ont commencé comme avant mais les
Français ils ne l'ont pas tourné la page
et ils ne veulent pas la tourner et elle
n'est pas tournée il y a une deuxième
proposition de référendum d'initiative
partagée sur lequel que la gauche a
déposé sur lequel le Conseil constitut
constitutionnel doit se prononcer de la
semaine prochaine je crois même la
suivante il y a des propositions de loi
d'abrogation de la loi de la réforme des
retraites qui ont été déposées notamment
à l'Assemblée nationale bref c'est loin
d'être fini et il reste un message que
nous portons mais surtout que l'immense
majorité des français portent c'est
prenant de la République renoncée à
votre réforme des retraites avant
qu'elle ne soit mise en oeuvre et ça
c'est toujours possible même si Emmanuel
Macron ne veut pas en entendre parler
donc vous continuez le combat contre
cette réforme on va parler de la
visitière du président de la République
dans le département de l'Hérault on va
retrouver nos partenaires du journal Le
Midi Libre avec Olivier Biscaye
directeur de la rédaction du journal Le
Midi Libre bonjour Olivier bonjour
Alexandre alors Emmanuel Macron était
hier à Ganges dans l'Hérault pour un
déplacement sur le thème de l'école
comment il a été accueilli
deux salles deux ambiances parce que si
vous étiez sur la place du marché de
Ganges petite commune de 4000 habitants
c'était à la fois très agité très
bruyant il y avait entre deux et trois
mille manifestants qui ont fait savoir
le reposition aux chefs de l'État un
concert de casserole au tout début
quelques œufs et puis beaucoup de
chansons et de siffler et puis il y
avait l'autre ambiance dans le collège
Louise-Michel une ambiance plus feutrée
vous l'imaginez bien plus plus
sympathique dans ce collège qui
accueillait le chef de l'État avec des
enfants des des enseignants et des
parents qui qui ont échangés avec lui
pendant près de deux heures d'ailleurs
le président de la République n'a pas
croisé un seul des manifestants la
commune de gangs était suffisamment
structuré pour pour éviter la moindre
rencontre même s'il a évoqué au député
Sébastien Rome la possibilité de
rencontrer des manifestants mais très
clairement hier l'ambiance était trop
survolté pour qu'il y ait le moindre
échange poser et d'écoute et puis le
président de la République vous a
consacré une interview qui est à lire
aujourd'hui dans les pages du Midi Libre
oui en effet aux sortir de cet échange
avec écollégiens et les parents il nous
a accordé cette interview dans laquelle
il revient sur les mesures qu'il a
précisé tout au long de sa journée
considérant qu'il faisait ce qu'il avait
annoncé pendant la campagne électorale
on a interrogé sur la réforme des
retraites il nous indique qu'il ne
reviendra pas sur cette réforme des
retraites il ne la retirera jamais ils
viennent la promulguer c'était un
engagement et par ailleurs tout au long
de cette entretien il a expliqué qu'il
voulait maintenant se consacrer à
l'essentiel c'est ce que disait le
sénateur Ferro tout à l'heure il veut
tourner la page des des retraites et se
concentrer sur des sujets dit-il du
quotidien des Français la ruralité on
faisait partie l'éducation l'emploi la
santé ou encore la sécurité et se
concentrer sur l'avenir du pays ce qui
m'importe maintenant c'est d'avancer
pour le pays a-t-il dit dans cette
interview et puis Olivier je crois que
vous souhaitiez rebondir sur une phrase
de cette interview notamment sur le lien
entre Emmanuel Macron et les Français
oui parce que il a indiqué dans cette
interview et c'est peut-être une
question au sénateur Rémi Féraud que lui
il allait sur le terrain il voulait
conserver ce lien avec les Français et
que malgré les désaccords et bien
c'était il était dans son rôle
finalement de d'être apportée de Gifs de
porter de claques mais d'être là aussi
au contact des Français pour expliquer
réexpliquer faire de la pédagogie
considérant qu'il avait sa part de
responsabilité est-ce que ça Rémi Féraud
c'est un élément qui permet non pas
d'avoir une autre image du président de
la République mais en tout cas de
considérer qu'il y a un autre temps qui
est en train d'installer entre le les
Français et le président de la
République ou est-ce que pour vous c'est
de la communication plus récente c'est
de la communication pure et simple et je
pense que
président de la République veut passer
un autre temps et il ne se rend pas
compte de ce qui se passe dans la
réalité du pays qu'il est dans la
brutalité qu'il a été pour faire passer
sa réforme des retraites mais qu'il est
aussi dans le déni
l'intervention la plus forte de cette
semaine c'est celle de Pierre
Rosanvallon quand il a expliqué la
gravité de la crise démocratique que
nous traversons et quand il a bien dit
que le Président de la République
respectait la lettre des institutions la
lettre de la Constitution mais pas
l'esprit des institutions et
Emmanuel Macron la renvoyé à un éventuel
rôle de militants vous voyez bien quand
on parle de Pierre rozanvallon ça ne
tient pas la route et vraiment je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron doit sortir de ce
déni d'autant que il doit penser à la
crise des gilets jaunes mais c'est très
différent la crise des gilets jaunes il
a retiré un certain nombre de mesures
avant de revenir sur le terrain là il
refuse de retirer une réforme des
retraites qui est extrêmement
traumatisante pour le pays et qui est
vécu comme une humiliation par les
Français prennent un public dit sont les
oppositions ils sont vexées de pas avoir
gagné la présidentielle c'est moi qui
préside le problème c'est que ça n'est
pas entre Emmanuel Macron et les
oppositions le sujet s'est entré
manuellement Macron et les Français et
l'esprit de nos institutions et de la
démocratie dans cette période très
particulière où il a été largement élu
par défaut et où il n'y a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale de
majorité claire je pense qu'il devrait
en tenir compte et est jamais trop tard
pour retirer une réforme qui n'est pas
encore rentrée en vigueur puisqu'elle
entre véritablement en vigueur au
premier septembre merci beaucoup Olivier
pour votre intervention regardez elle a
une du Midi Libre aujourd'hui qui est
consacrée à cette visite d'Emmanuel
Macron au contact des gens hier dans le
département de l'Hérault Rémi Féraud
hier Emmanuel Macron a quand même fait
des annonces des précisions concernant
une hausse de la rémunération des
enseignants une hausse pour déjà tous
les enseignants quel que soit leur
niveau de carrière entre 100 et 30 euros
par mois vous saluez cette hausse de
rémunération de rémunération ce sont des
annonces un peu réchauffées parce que je
crois que Papé Ndiaye avait fait ces
mêmes annonces il y a déjà quelques mois
et je ne sais pas d'ailleurs si les
montants étaient exactement les mêmes
donc on sent bien la santé enseignants
sont un peu déçus oui on voit bien la
volonté prendre la République de
retrouver un peu de popularité je
pourrais regarder dans les chiffres en
tout cas les chiffres ils sont loin
d'être à la hauteur là aussi du besoin
de revalorisation de la condition
enseignante c'est pas si ce sont des
salaires ou des primes il y a il faut
les mettre en rapport aussi avec
l'inflation bref je me méfie beaucoup de
ce de ce genre d'annonce dont voilà qui
sont faites comme ça pour essayer de
tourner la page des retraites et
beaucoup plus que pour véritablement
avoir une politique de l'école donc
[Musique]
il y a aussi un second volet de la
hausse de rémunération des enseignants
qui prév et bien une hausse et une prime
pour les enseignants qui accepteraient
de faire de nouvelles missions comme
l'aide aux devoirs ou et bien la
conduite de projets pédagogiques c'est
la bonne méthode se travailler plus pour
gagner plus pour l'école non et surtout
c'est pas la bonne méthode que de faire
des annonces comme ça sans aucun travail
visiblement préparatoire avec les
organisations
syndicales vraiment on est dans les
effets d'annonce avec cette part là de
travailler plus pour gagner plus qui est
dit d'ailleurs par président de la
République c'était également 10 par
Jean-Michel Blanquer voilà régulièrement
sans que cela ne recouvre rien de réel
moi voilà je pense que ça c'est vraiment
pas la bonne méthode pour aujourd'hui
affronter les problèmes de l'école et
revaloriser les salaires des enseignants
non alors selon vous ces annonces ne
tournent pas la page de la réforme des
retraites vous continuez continuez le
combat je reviens sur et bien c'est les
initiatives des parlementaires de gauche
pour essayer d'abroger ce texte avec des
proposition de loi notamment des
sénateurs socialistes et des sénateurs
communistes est-ce que vous savez quand
est-ce que ça va être discuter au Sénat
alors au Sénat je n'en sais rien non je
crois que ce sont des sénateurs
communistes qui ont déposé une
proposition de loi je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'ils ont une niche pour la
discuter mais est-ce que cette c'est
d'abord l'Assemblée nationale que cette
essentiel parce qu'au Sénat connais la
majorité sénatoriale et la voté la
réforme des retraites même si beaucoup
de sénateurs de la majorité ne l'ont pas
voté mais c'est vraiment à l'Assemblée
nationale que
un vote peut être différent de celui sur
la motion de censure parce que si la
réforme des retraites avait été mise au
vote de l'Assemblée nationale elle
n'aurait probablement pas été voté
d'ailleurs sinon le gouvernement
n'aurait pas déclenché le 49-3 donc vous
croyez à une future censure du
gouvernement censure du gouvernement je
ne sais pas même si je l'espère en tout
cas vote d'une loi d'une proposition de
loi d'abrogation de la loi de réforme
des retraites je pense que c'est tout à
fait envisageable il y a la gauche puis
il y a aussi le groupe liotte je crois
qui a déposé une proposition de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale oui oui je pense
que c'est tout à fait possible et ce
serait même une façon de sortir de la
crise en retirant cette réforme on va
parler des finances publiques Rémy Ferro
puisque hier Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel
Attal ont présenté leur stratégie de
réduction du déficit de l'État et de la
dette de la France et il prévoit je cite
un refroidissement des dépenses
publiques pour redresser nos comptes
est-ce que ce refroidissement ou cette
baisse des dépenses publiques elle n'est
pas inéluctable compte tenu de la
situation économique de la situation
financière de notre pays non elle n'est
pas du tout inéluctable il y a c'est un
choix de politique
fiscale budgétaire économique et je ne
partage absolument pas les perspectives
de annoncé hier par par Bruno Le Maire
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire soit les
chiffres annoncés par le gouvernement ne
tiennent pas la route puisque on ne voit
pas vraiment sur quoi
[Musique]
les voix des républicains je pense que
toute la communication du gouvernement
est un clin d'oeil aux républicains
gouvernement dira une main tendue j'ai
pas l'impression que les républicains
aient envie de saisir une main
impopulaire mais idéologiquement sur le
fond politique au néo aujourd'hui dans
une
proximité vraiment il y a plus beaucoup
de feuilles de papier à cigarette entre
les républicains et la politique du
gouvernement Rémi Ferron évoqué une
affaire qui préoccupe je le disais dans
le début de cette émission les
parlementaires de gauche l'affaire du
fond Marianne le fond Marianne c'est un
fond gouvernemental qui a été créé pour
lutter contre la radicalisation en ligne
il est suspecté d'avoir été utilisé à
des fins politiques contre les
adversaires d'Emmanuel Macron à la
dernière présidentielle on en parle avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Quentin
Calmet
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Alexandre
bonjour Rémi Féraud bonjour alors la Pol
se poursuit sur cette affaire du fond
Marianne après les révélations de France
Télévisions exactement c'est l'affaire
du moment avec son lot de révélation et
maintenant le Parlement et qui s'en
emparent progressivement alors point de
départ avril 2021 Marlène Schiappa est
alors ministre délégué à la citoyenneté
six mois après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty elle annonce un fond dédié à la
lutte contre la radicalisation en ligne
dotée de 2,5 millions d'euros il vise à
financer je cite des personnes et
associations qui vont porter des
discours pour promouvoir les valeurs de
la République et lutter contre les
discours séparatistes c'est ce que dit
alors Marlène Schiappa sur BFM TV
patatra il y a trois semaines France
Télévisions et journal Marianne font des
révélations parmi les associations qui
ont bénéficié de ce fond il y en a
plusieurs qui interrogent par exemple
celle qui s'appelle l'Union des sociétés
d'éducation physique et aide à la
préparation militaire elle aurait
utilisé le fond Marianne pour un site
internet mais aussi pour cette page
YouTube avec d'ailleurs une efficacité
assez peu probante quelques dizaines de
vues et des publications donc sur les
réseaux sociaux très peu suivi ce n'est
pas tout écoutez à ce propos la
journaliste d'un investigation Sophie
broyet on l'a rencontré cette semaine à
notre équipe notamment Mathias arez a pu
lui parler c'est elle qui a travaillé
sur le fond Marianne pour France
Télévisions elle répondait à nos
questions écoutez pour un budget aussi
colossal 355000 euros
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière qu'est-ce
qui a été produit et du coup on creuse
on creuse en Creuse et puis
effectivement on a pu récupérer des
pièces et essayer de comprendre aussi ce
qui a été fait de ce budget et on
s'aperçoit sur la base de documents
bancaires que une très grande partie de
cette subvention a servi à rémunérer les
deux dirigeants de cette association et
je rappelle bien que des dirigeants
administrateurs d'une association
contenue des statues non absolument pas
le droit de se rémunérer ça c'est juste
d'un point de vue légal c'est imparable
une deuxième association serait
également épinglée pour avoir créé des
contenus politiques pendant les
campagnes présidentielles et
législatives avec des vidéos notamment
qui ciblaient Anne Hidalgo on va y
revenir et puis cette affaire est
devenue politique cette semaine puisque
le Parlement s'en est emparé voilà on
entendait les critiques monter à gauche
surtout depuis que les révélations
étaient publiées et alors que au même
moment et bien l'exécutif dénonçait
l'action de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme il y a eu ce moment qui s'est
rencontré politiquement ici
gauche aimeraient que le Sénat tout
entier s'empare du sujet et créer une
commission d'enquête sur la création le
fonctionnement l'utilisation des fonds
et la modalité de sélection des
structures financées ainsi que le
contrôle par son autorité de tutelle du
fond Marianne c'est ce que veut le
groupe socialiste en loi c'est la
résolution qui est porté ici par le
groupe pour l'entièreté du Sénat autre
initiative Claude rénale que cette photo
le président socialiste de la commission
des finances du Sénat a demandé à ce
qu'on lui livre mercredi des documents
liés à ce fond il les a reçu via une clé
USB et bien ils sont analysés en ce
moment par les équipes de la commission
des Affaires la commission des finances
on aura le détail un peu plus tard dans
la journée en début de semaine Rémi
Féraud est-ce que nous sommes au cœur
d'une affaire d'état selon vous je crois
et le gouvernement essaye de banaliser
de ne pas répondre d'ailleurs pour
essayer qu'on en parle pas mais enfin
gouvernement a aussi sa casserole donc
je pense que c'est un scandale d'État à
la fois pour le détournement de fonds
publics la gabegie d'argent public et
aussi évidemment pour l'utilisation qui
en aurait été faite dans le cadre des
échéances électorales de 2022 ce qui est
très grave il faut absolument à la fois
que la justice soit saisie je crois que
maintenant elle l'est par des plaintes
mais on est vraiment aussi dans les
responsabilités du contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement par le Parlement c'est
pour ça que nous souhaitons une
commission d'enquête parlementaire alors
sur Paris on peut évoquer effectivement
Anne Hidalgo puisqu'elle a porté plainte
contre X auprès de la procureur de la
République de Paris pour je cite
détournement de fonds publics abus de
confiance c'est ça c'est qu'en fait
certaines vidéos donc financées par le
fond Marianne viser véritable la mère de
Paris c'est ça que vous reprochez bien
sûr et
tous les Français doivent aussi avoir la
certitude que leur argent et bien
utilisé
aux fins pour lequel ils ont payé des
impôts et là que il y a un détournement
de fonds publics c'est grave qu'il y a
un détournement de fonds publics afin de
décrédibiliser de salir les adversaires
d'Emmanuel Macron dont un Hidalgo à
l'élection présidentielle c'est
extrêmement grave ça influait sur la
campagne je n'en sais rien je n'en sais
rien mais que des fonds publics soient
venus alimenter une campagne ça cache
Paris pour être très clair que rien à
voir avec la laïcité la lutte contre la
radicalisation pour dénigrer une
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
et peut-être d'autres candidatures
également c'est extrêmement grave et le
fait que le gouvernement joue la
politique du silence en espérant que ça
se passe
je dois plutôt inspirer de la méfiance
qu'autre chose et donc c'est pour ça que
nous voulons que le Sénat se saisisse
vraiment du sujet sous forme de
commission d'enquête parlementaire le
gouvernement reste silencieux est-ce que
Marlène chappa qui était ministre en
charge de ce fond à l'époque à une
responsabilité dans cette affaire selon
vous cette
quête de le démontrer mais en tout cas
les articles de Mediapart semble
conduire dans cette direction quelle est
sa part de responsabilité je peux pas le
dire à ce moment-là mais la volonté du
gouvernement de ne répondre à aucune
question des médias après avoir
déclenché une enquête administrative
doit quand même nous inspirer d'abord de
la méfiance et de la volonté de
transparence elle renvoie beaucoup un
vers le préfet Christian Gravel qui est
d'ailleurs et le secrétaire général du
comité interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation
qui est ce comité qui aurait sélectionné
les associations pour être dotées
ensuite de subventions du fond Marianne
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cela est-ce
que d'ailleurs il faudrait entendre
Christian très rapidement aux sous
serment au Sénat c'est une commission
d'enquête ce sera le casse pour ça qu'il
y a besoin d'une commission d'enquête
d'ailleurs mais la volonté de Marlène
siapa de refiler la patate chaude les
gens se renvoient la responsabilité
et refuse voilà de s'exprimer de
s'expliquer ça en fait le gouvernement
ne pourra pas en rester là ça n'est pas
possible et le fait que nous en parlions
ce matin que la presse en parle que les
parlementaires s'en saisissent c'est
absolument nécessaire et puis pour qu'il
y ait une commission d'enquête du Sénat
il faut qu'il y ait un vote favorable de
la majorité du Sénat et ce que selon
vous les sénateurs de droite sont en
coulisses favorable à la création de
cette commission d'enquête je n'ai pas
échangé avec les collègues des
républicains mais le Sénat a montré
toujours sa détermination ces dernières
années dans le contrôle du gouvernement
la vie au moment de l'affaire Benalla on
l'a vu sur les cabinets de conseils moi
j'ai pas vraiment de doute de la volonté
du Sénat d'exercer cette mission de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
donc vous pensez qu'elle sera créée moi
je pense que oui merci beaucoup Quentin
on se retrouve dans le club des
territoires et on parlera de la notion
de crise démocratique actuellement
on va finir cette entretien par des
questions politiques et notamment on va
aborder et bien les prochaines élections
sénatoriales en septembre est-ce que à
Paris il y aura une liste d'unions de la
gauche entre des socialistes des
communistes voire des écologistes comme
le souhaite à la mère de Paris à nidalgo
je ne sais pas encore si nous y
parviendrons mais en tout cas nous
sommes vraiment ouvert je parle des
socialistes à une liste qui est à une
liste oui qui réunissent l'ensemble de
la majorité municipale de gauche donc je
crois que les communistes sont tout à
fait partants et c'est une bonne
nouvelle et la proposition elle est
évidemment elle s'adresse aussi aux
écologistes au vert donc si nous pouvons
nous réunir sur une seule liste ce sera
parfait mais c'est pas une injonction
c'est pas une obligation chaque parti
politique voilà bordera comme il le
souhaite mais en tout cas nous sommes
ouverts à une liste réunissent
l'ensemble de la gauche municipale
est-ce qu'il devrait y avoir sur cette
liste notamment l'adjoint au logement de
la maire de Paris à nidalgo Ian brossa
qui est communiste c'est une possibilité
c'est pas à moi de répondre à la part à
la place des communistes qui n'ont pas
encore pris leur décision je crois que
c'est d'ici l'été mais si c'est le cas
c'est en tout cas une très bonne
nouvelle et puis est-ce qu'il y aura et
bien sur cette liste de gauche à Paris
la candidature de Laurence Rossignol
l'ancienne ministre de François Hollande
en charge de la famille des droits des
femmes et qui est actuelle sénatrice
socialiste de l'Oise le problème c'est
que elle ne va pas avoir
vraisemblablement l'investiture au
sénatorial dans l'Oise est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'elle ait une place sur
cette liste à Paris pas vous répondre à
cette question et je ne veux pas vous
répondre à cette question comme cela
Laurence Rossignol c'est une scénatrice
remarquable son rôle politique sont
engagement féministe sont extrêmement
reconnus et précieux pour le Parti
socialiste elle est sénatrice sortante
de l'Oise et souhaite se représenter
moi je souhaite que le Parti socialiste
prenne ses responsabilités et
propose soutiennent la candidature de
Laurence Rossignol dans l'Oise si ça
n'était pas le cas
évidemment peut discuter mais je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse commencer les
choses comme cela je pense que le Parti
socialiste doit prendre ses
responsabilités et soutenir la
candidature de Laurence Rossignol dans
son département dans l'Oise là aussi
c'est tout à fait possible donc
notamment c'est Olivier Faure de et bien
maintenir Laurence Rossignol sur une
liste dans l'Oise alors que pour
l'instant et bien c'est plutôt un
candidat proche d'Olivier fort qui est
préférée à Olivier Faure et la direction
du Parti socialiste ainsi qu'à la
fédération de l'Oise là aussi de prendre
les responsabilités et de voir quel est
l'intérêt politique des socialistes je
crois que c'est que Laurence puisse être
à nouveau candidate dans l'Oise la place
de président du groupe socialiste au
Sénat sera également en jeu alors qu'une
partie dessinateur socialistes
soutiennent Olivier FA la tête du PS
contrairement à Patrick Kanner l'actuel
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
est-ce que vous craignez que Patrick
canner ne perde sa présidence de groupe
on n'a pas encore voilà d'abord on va
désigner les candidats ensuite il va y
avoir les élections seatoriales ensuite
sur du président du président de groupe
je ne sais pas quels seront les
candidats ne brûlaient pas les étapes
comme cela mais je pense que Patrick
kaner est un très bon président du
groupe socialiste mais les divisions
internes du PS vont forcément avoir un
rôle à jouer dans dans le groupe au
Sénat un rôle à jouer oui mais il y a
beaucoup d'autres dimensions qui jouent
un rôle au Sénat ça n'est pas un
décalque des différentes positions au
sein du Parti socialiste c'est plus
compliqué que cela merci beaucoup pour
cet entretien Rémy Ferro merci à vous
d'avoir été le sénateur du jour
dans 20 minutes le club des territoires
nous reviendrons sur la semaine
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a tenté tant bien
que mal de renouer le contact avec les
Français et de lancer certains chantiers
pour essayer de tourner la page de la
réforme des retraites on verra on verra
si c'est une opération réussie et dans
un instant et bien j'accueille mes
invités pour parler bande dessinée et
politique